that's where he belongs to the DAR Wolff
has no place in the south will you take
him with you he'll be happier up there
so would you
you
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight video in this video I will be
talking about what one of the Game of
Thrones actors had to say about their
characters ending as you all know I like
to keep everyone up to date with any and
all Game of Thrones related news
we haven't heard this actor say much
ever since the show ended so I thought
some of you would like to know what he
had to say so let's go ahead and get
right into it the first thing I want to
do is read one of the Articles that was
written on the actors thoughts this gave
a good description of Jon Snow's journey
throughout the show which ultimately led
him back to the far north beyond the
wall this is what the article and the
actor had to say express.com said Game
of Thrones came to a dramatic end last
year but now former star Kit Harington
has dropped the bombshell to fans
regarding the final season of the show
the HBO drama ran for eight seasons
before it came to a climactic end last
summer which saw
Kitt's character Jon Snow murder his
lover Daenerys Targaryen in a gruesome
twist the ending was a bitter pill to
swallow for many fans who felt it had
been rushed and KITT recently admitted
he has never got around to watching his
final scenes on-screen Jon Snow was one
of the central characters to the show
throughout and after he was supposedly
killed off in season five some fans
thought they'd seen the last of him
however it wasn't long before he made an
unexpected reappearance after he was
brought back to life by Melisandre in
the following season further on into the
saga Jon sealed his romance with
Daenerys whilst the pair remained
unaware they were related
heathyr a further curveball after
revealing his true identity to Daenerys
and made her vow to keep it a secret as
they continued their quest to claim the
Iron Throne his true name was exposed as
Aegon Targaryen which made him the heir
to the Seven Kingdoms threatening
Daenerys his future on the throne he
insisted he had no interest in trying to
take away from her potential role but
she was unable to cope with the
revelation she later went on a killing
spree murdering thousands of innocent
citizens in King's Landing as she
overthrew Cersei Lannister which led to
Jon feeling he had no
choice but to assassinate her John Cena
was banished after to the north by brain
stark who was declared the king of the
six kingdoms the ending of the
long-running show received criticism
from fans after they felt there were
multiple plot holes still left open
leaving them with plenty of questions
however KITT is yet to give the finale a
watch as said in a recent Q&A with
purple dragon the star stunned fans by
revealing I haven't seen it he added
when people say to me I wished you'd
been on the throne or I wished you'd
been with Danny on the throne I disagree
because John's place was always in the
north
he's never been happy in the south he's
like Ned Stark when Ned goes to the
south he's in danger she's been on the
throne I wish she'd been with Danny on
the throne I disagree because John's
place was always in the north he'd never
have been happy in the south he's like
Ned Stark but Ned goes south he's in
danger John is always happiest like it's
when torment says to him you're Europe
the north your new you know you're it's
right he belongs north of the world and
actually what I try I haven't seen it so
I don't know if I managed to pull off
but what I tried to do the ending was
show some you know he's been saddled
with this weight all the way through the
series and he's his heavy character he's
literally got a cloak on and he's heavy
and what I wanted that last bit isn't
best to be a sort of lightness about him
that it's all falling off that this
terrible thing he's been through it's
just just falling off as he goes north I
could go on about this for us John
belongs north of the wall all right now
let's break it down let's talk about
what he said first which is him saying
he has yet to watch the final episode
I'm sure some of you might be wondering
why that is well to be honest there are
always a number of different reasons why
some actors may never watch their own
work however we may already know why kid
Harrington decided not to revisit
Westeros after the show ended it might
still be too emotional for him if you
remember right after HBO released their
documentary on the
making of the final-season Herrington
actually checked himself into a wellness
facility for some much-needed therapy
there were many articles written on this
at the time as well a friend of the
actor added that the end of the
decade-long show really hit kid hard in
his wife fellow Game of Thrones actress
Rose Leslie was being extremely
supportive the Thrones documentary the
last watch was also released Sunday that
showed Harrington crying in dismay when
he first learned that his character Jon
Snow would kill the show's female lead
Daenerys Targaryen the actor also told
Esquire in April that he broke down
after shooting his final scenes as the
character the final day of shooting I
felt fine I felt fine I felt fine they
don't want to do my last shots and
started hyperventilating a bit then they
called a wrap and I just broke down it
was this onslaught of relief and grief
about not being able to do this again
now this is just a guess
but I think this might have something to
do with the fact that he has yet to
watch the final episode it's too
emotional for him and I would completely
understand if that were the case the
show had been a part of his life for
nearly a decade and not only that but
this was also the show that made his
career and completely changed his life
for better or worse he had also become
very close with so many of the actors on
the show in fact he even married Rose
Leslie someone he shared scenes with for
multiple seasons so you can see how Game
of Thrones had a major impact on his
life I had a feeling that even I would
get emotional while watching the last
episode so I can only imagine what he
had to be going through during those
final days on set it had to be a
rollercoaster of emotions for everyone
involved you would be very happy for
accomplishing something of that
magnitude but also sad because it's
finally coming to an end and you might
even worry if you'll ever be a part of
something that's successful again so
like I said I totally understand why he
might not want to watch this series
finale just yet it might take some more
time before he's ready to watch himself
as that character again I also want to
mention I am happy kid Harrington is no
longer in therapy it was very
unfortunate to hear about some of the
issues he was having but I was also glad
that he did the right thing by seeking
out profession
oh hell I hope he's in a happier place
now I want to give my thoughts on what
he said about Jon Snow's ending he
essentially said he agreed with where
Jon Snow ended up he felt that the
character belongs in the north and I
have to say I do agree with him and the
writers choice for those of you who
followed my videos for years you would
know I always said Jon Snow will never
become king it was so obvious that it
was something he never wanted now
although I do wish Jon Snow was the one
to kill the night king I was still happy
to see him go back in to the far north
at the end from the very first episode
of the show this is where Jon Snow was
meant to spend the rest of his life even
though he was betrayed by certain
members of the Nights Watch not only
that but Jon was never gonna fit
anywhere else just like his direwolf
ghost Jon was the outcast of the bunch
and once he met Ygritte Mance Rayder and
even torment you could see how much of
an impact and influence they had on him
even some of the decisions Jon made
later on in this series were directly
connected to some of the decisions mance
rayder either made or would have made
after spending so much time with the
free folk Jon would never be the same
again so I understood why the character
would want to go back beyond the wall
I believe I even said in my review of
the final episode when we see Jon go
beyond the wall for the last time he
watches as the door closes behind him
and I think it was a good representation
of Jon entering a new chapter in his
life he was leaving behind Westeros and
all the chaos that came with it for Jon
life is much simpler in the north and
just like with the actor who portrayed
him I hope he can find happiness moving
forward I wish I was going with you
mrs. farewell that you never know
but as always these are just my opinions
feel free to let me know what you think
down below why do you think he still
hasn't watched the final episode and
what did you think of Jon Snow's ending
do you still think and feel the same way
you did a year ago when the finale first
aired I would like to see what all of
you have to say about it anyways thanks
for stopping by to watch the video I
appreciate that as always and I also
want to thank you for supporting the
channel I hope you all have a great day
I will see you again soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
you